hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to don't chat with
strangers now you guys told me that
there actually is an end to this game
and it's obscenely complicated to
actually get to so I'm gonna go into it
and I'm gonna say actually a few more
times before I'm done with it but
there's a certain number of steps that
you need to take to be able to get to
the place that you need to go now that
doesn't make sense
well it doesn't really make sense to me
I'm pulling this from memory so I may
not actually remember this but I wanted
to do a few more things before I
actually go here there's a few more
deaths that I did not explore I'm not
100% sure what snores snooze snubs Oh
what is that hey why is there a plunger
going down from the ceiling that sounds
like that seems like something I should
be concerned about maybe I didn't order
this I didn't want this this isn't mine
can you send this back to where it came
from
oh no I mean I mean get up quick so we
gonna do anything about that we're gonna
do anything about that big old cross in
the middle verb you're gonna do anything
about that
hello welp I'm dead anyway so what does
that matter oh oh
doubles oh I get doubles Oh fun
fantastic times great good for me so you
say hi to Lussier whatever name is same
zzzz
oh no I've already goofed it I've
already goofed it I think it was gonna
blow me up now apparently not okay we're
still good what was it whoa what's your
favorite color red the color of blood
dude resting I imagine hell is whole red
probably why not okay so after you get
this you got to write down the phone
number I'm not prepared for this so you
needed to turn the radio on at the
beginning and you needed to turn the
light on as well to dis ways to the
black goopy thing from getting over
there but every time you hear like a
clatter or a booby dupe or a gas leak
over in the yonder way you gotta click
on your door and then immediately
back on your chair or else you're gonna
take pills and go to sleep and die well
I didn't do that
why I didn't do that no I didn't I
didn't do that I didn't do that
that's that wasn't me when did that get
done I didn't do I didn't call the cross
I didn't call for a cross delivery you
sack of [ __ ] you piece of poop
well I'm gonna die now this is great I
don't know why this is working well
there we go
too late I'm dead I don't know why that
happened I didn't turn that upside down
did I wouldn't have I did nothing of
thorns if this number is 7 3 1 4 6 0 4 2
okay so then you immediately go on the
phone
you're like Sabol 1 3 1 4 6 0 4 2 that's
a train train so remember train ok chat
oh oh well that ain't good I'm gonna go
do that real quick ok and then go back
to the chair ok got it got it got it
oh you have any hobbies playing video
games is my favorite hobby I love that
that's great it's my favorite thing to
do love mech vs. fruits it's a great
game then you got to play game of mech
versus fruits and you got to get pretty
far it's pretty difficult no I've never
beaten it before never ever ever can i
watch you play anyway yeah ok I'll start
up the game then and then I actually got
to be good at this game you got to be
careful about this because I ain't gonna
be I'm gonna be thwarted ok I think I
just need to get to more levels and then
I'm good kill this boss right oh god
that was close that was too close
oh those guys gonna woo those were guys
were gonna mess up my day ok
hey ieave that was risky I don't know
why I bothered to do that well okay
got that level oh boy this looks bad
well wait no nevermind we got it
want to hear me play yes and then you
say yes to that and this is why you this
is why you turned on the radio before
because if you turned it on later it
would have blown up oh no oh come on
I was waiting for god damn I okay I'll
be right back
I didn't hear anything why didn't I hear
oh [ __ ]
well playing video games one no nazo
team always barmy next to one horrible
oh oh oh whoa whoa I'm Blaine meant room
what huh
[Applause]
it's too late what too late
what kind of buggy ass piece of [ __ ] is
this let me read the guide make sure I'm
not missing a step here because this
[ __ ] ah that makes sense so as soon
as I say yes to hearing her play I'm out
makes sense
the [ __ ] I have no idea what that was
okay now I'll just wait okay gotta go
gotta go gotta go now
now I can go but I don't know what place
I found her that's the thing cuz oh man
this water I'm assuming that's my house
I'm gonna go here in the woods I don't
know if that's correct
[Music]
is it right no oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] why do I feel like I really need to
hurry
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy kicked my
foot every time God didn't make any
sense this is the reverse of what it was
the floor oh my god my head screaming up
so badly oh winner that's it
I thought you give me that it's just
that excuse you
that's it that's it that's all you get I
was hoping that was gonna be satisfying
not hand cramping and horrible anyway
alright I'm being too mean about it
without anticlimactic but that's how you
beat it now there are other ways to die
in this there are mysterious other ways
to die it is true with that being said
aggravating but interesting it's still
interesting in that it captivated me to
come back to it that is that much is
true but even so I'll leave it up to you
guys to judge so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know you
thought it down in the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]